How many of you heard of Alzheimer's
disease?
That's a physician caused disease. Mark
my words. Mark my words in the next 2
years, maybe even next week it'll pop up
in the newspaper. There's more than
enough information
to prove that it's a physician caused
disease.
Um Alzheimer's disease is a disease that
did not occur, even by another name, 40
years ago. It only became recognized as
a disease 1979,
25 years ago. Today it's the number four
killer of adults over the age of 65,
behind
Well, I have to throw in doctors now.
Doctors, um cardiovascular disease,
cancer, diabetes, and Alzheimer's
disease.
Now, our brains
are made up of 75% a fatty insulation
material called myelin. How many of you
heard of myelin? Good. Well, myelin is
this fatty insulation material in the
brain. How many of you eaten a brain
sandwich, brain and egg sandwich?
Oh, you haven't lived until you eat a
brain sandwich. It is good.
A little bit of onion and mustard. I
mean, there's nothing better than a
brain sandwich. It's real cheap now cuz
everybody's afraid of, you know, mad cow
disease. So, I buy more brains and I eat
it.
But anyway,
this myelin makes up 75% of our brain
weight. It's so important to the animal
and human brain. Myelin is 75% of our
brain weight. And myelin is 100%
cholesterol.
You know, I make 10% of your daily need.
The other 90% must come from your food.
If you're very, very good at listening
to your doctor's instructions,
does that sound familiar? September
2000, Scientific American.
If you listen to your doctor and you
give up eggs and eat egg beaters, if you
give up butter and eat margarine, if you
rip the chicken skin off your chicken
before you eat it, you eat tofu instead
of red meat,
the odds are you're going to get what?
Alzheimer's disease.
This came out 4 years ago, March of
2000.
Alzheimer's tidal wave is feared is
coming. They said within the next 25
years, 14 million Americans are going to
die of Alzheimer's disease. Today, 25
years backwards, only 250,000 died of
it. And 25 years backwards from that,
nobody died from Alzheimer's disease.
Now, why would you go from zero to
250,000
to 14 million? Well, that's because the
baby boomers are coming along and they
listened to the doctors. They believed
in technology. And they believed in
doctors, and they believed if they
followed the doctor's advice, they could
be healthier and live to be 100. And so
now, baby boomers are the ones who get a
higher
rate and higher percentage of
Alzheimer's disease than our older
relatives who could care less.
Okay?
Remember Ralph Charles, still flying
airplanes at 100? Harold Stilson, still
hitting
in golf, hole-in-one at 101?
Mazumi Dosti, 161,
still babysitting and singing lullabies
and
maybe cooking and sewing.
We eliminated Alzheimer's disease in
animals 65 years ago.
This is a human study that came out
in July of 1992. Vitamin E can ease
memory loss in Alzheimer's patients.
This was a study by the University of
California, San Diego
uh medical school and the Salk
Institute, infamous for the Salk polio
vaccine.
They said that
vitamin E could bring back a certain
amount of memory and and make people
functional again. Well, nobody could
believe that was true, so they redid the
study and 5 years later, they came out
with this. Vitamin E might slow
Alzheimer's disease. High doses of
common vitamin E can slow the
devastating decline for some Alzheimer's
patients, significantly delaying the
need for nursing home care.
Again, the University of California, San
Diego University Medical School.
Now, if you can delay the need for
nursing home care for a spouse or a
child or a parent, grandparent, aunt,
uncle who has Alzheimer's disease by 5
years, would that be emotionally and
financially beneficial to a family? Of
course, it would.
Why don't doctors tell you this? Well,
because they own the stock in the
nursing home in your town that takes
care of Alzheimer's patients. They don't
want this to get out.
This came out
in 2003, November 2003, a study by Tufts
University Medical School in Boston.
They found out you could reduce your
risk of Alzheimer's disease by 48%
by just taking
uh either supplements or fish three
times a day to get the omega-3 essential
fatty acids.
This has been repeated over and over and
over.
This just came out
January 2004.
People taking vitamins C and E were 78%
less less likely to have a diagnosis of
Alzheimer's disease.
Now,
they didn't even think about the diet,
getting rid of fried foods and
margarines and sources of free radicals.
They didn't even think about eating
cholesterol. This is just some
antioxidants. And so, we know from
animal studies and and these sort of um
early studies in human beings that if
you eat enough cholesterol, not fried,
not cooked in margarine, but poached and
uh soft boiled and hard boiled and and
soft scrambled in butter and meat medium
rare and so forth, which we'll talk
about in a minute,
and take in antioxidants, the odds of
you getting Alzheimer's disease are
reduced almost zero.
I I have to go ask my doctor.
He's only a little bitty 56. Why would
you ask him?
>> I love it.